what is Sanjaya doing right now okay
guys it is Thursday here on it's Grace
and it's time for tipsy Thursday which
means I teach you how to do something
because clearly I am an expert I'm going
on my tumblr blog and I asked you guys
what did you want to learn how to do
today and someone said how to
successfully pull an all-nighter now
I've got to school a few times and I can
say what a few times I've got to school
and I can say that I've had to study
four things and I've you know loaded
myself up with a lot of last-minute work
and some nights I have to stay up all
night and pull an all-nighter I'm pretty
much an expert so today I'm going to
teach you how to pull an all-nighter
first thing you do get your hands set
and then
first of all great so it's your second
of all stop we all know if you watch
Papa Roach what was it shut it down
yeah I'm sorry the frozen computer shut
it down
it's really this is like little kids
selling lemonade and you just want to
tell them like this is no no this won't
make you money shut it down well you
definitely farted while that was
happening how did you do this
what chemicals did you mix in your
intestine to create this scent